ecuador podría convertirse en centro de
nuevas movilizaciones ante el
rompimiento de un acuerdo para el
reconteo de votos para definir quién
será el candidato que enfrente andrés
araus en segunda vuelta electoral
guillermo lasso y ya q pérez habían
acordado ante el cine y la oea un
reconteo de votos en 16 provincias del
país pero este acuerdo ahora fue
rechazado por guillermo lasso quien
publicó una carta en donde condiciona su
realización si es aprobado por los otros
candidatos participantes lazos sostiene
que la apertura de actas debe realizarse
en las obras denunciadas y lo previsto
en la ley electoral mientras tanto las
organizaciones indígenas anuncian nuevas
movilizaciones por el rompimiento del
acuerdo en otro tema el fiscal general
de colombia francisco barbosa entregó a
su pares de ecuador diana salazar
supuesta información encontrada en un
dispositivo digital de andrés vanegas
londoño alias uriel ex jefe de la ln
muerte en una operación militar con
presuntos archivos de l'urgell
demostrando el interés de la ln en la
campaña electoral ecuatoriana donde se
señala de un supuesto por préstamo de
campaña dirigido al candidato andrés
araus rechazado por el propio candidato
con este escenario observadores
internacionales calificaron la visita
del funcionario como una intervención
del gobierno colombiano y un intento de
golpe de estado a pocos meses de una
segunda vuelta electoral el debate se
centra en si se podrá descalificar al
candidato a araos y las decisiones que
tomará hoy el consejo nacional electoral